Ryan you come in to this new venture
with this incredible track record this
incredible brand the business of selling
suits is it's not an easy one why did
you decide you wanted to jump into this
I love a great suit part of my job on a
regular basis for almost 15 years has to
been put on a great suit and go out and
host a show and there's there's a moment
where you put that suit on you get into
it and you feel a sense of of confidence
and you feel a sense of optimism and I
think that that that feeling is is what
we're looking at with this line and how
involved do you want to be your busy guy
I've got a lot on the go I want to be as
involved as the people who are experts
want me to be you know I don't profess
to know everything about this world I
know what I like I know I have a point
of view
I like style I like to dress and I like
to convey my thoughts in terms aren't
necessarily fashion vocabulary and so
Duran translates them I'll say you know
great lines great architecture like I'm
talking about a house you know say oh
you mean it's something about the pants
it sounds so much smarter than what I
said but I do think that these suits are
different their unique they've got great
detail and I think it's a good time to
launch them there have been a lot of
partnerships over the last decade where
you have seen designers and others come
to big retails become a really important
part of the business I mean as you were
putting this together did you have any
inspirations on what the business model
should be like based on some someone
else you saw or something else you saw I
did a little bit of research myself I
called a few people that had done things
in this universe before and asked them
about their experiences and asked them
about how they put their deals together
so I did a little self education i sat
with Duran and his team in New York and
we talked about the timing of this the
research that they had the the amount of
oomph that was going to be behind the
launch in the campaign where we'd open
how the expectations would be managed so
I think we both went into this pretty
well researched how will you decide
whether you're gonna wear your clothing
line or other clothing lines for all
big TV events I think my line is perfect
for all of those occasions so I'm
excited to show off my line I mean this
is something that everything from the
way the pockets are cut the way the
pants are made the way that the lapel is
done will pail my way you're wearing the
p2p thank you I mean these are things
that that we've put our heart and soul
into creating and things that I'm proud
of so it's a priority to show this line
off we want to get it right out of the
gate
um first impressions these suits are
about first impressions you know you
talk about Millennials and getting their
first suit or going out for their first
interview or first meeting for a job
that's about a first impression this
launch is a first impression